so this is uh ee 380 for uh uh May 10th
uh 2023 and our speaker is uh Ken Khan
who is retired in Oxford after being at
Oxford
and soon we'll be back at us
um Ken Ken was uh back in the uh Dark
Ages at Xerox park for a bit and there
he worked on a project which became a
a lifetime Obsession I guess call
toontalk which was the first uh really
configurable programmable animation
system
and in its day
um
oh yeah I hate to think of how long ago
there was uh he was was was really the
most amazing thing and rather than go
the commercial route and and build video
games it can kept poking away at the
methodology and the underlying
structures of which you tell stories
through pictures and voice
um
he recently did some work collaborating
with uh chat jpt4 and
unlike a lot of people who looked at it
as using it as a tool hey he appears to
uh to believe as I do that chatgpt4 is
just another programming companion a
worker a colleague and used it in a very
interesting way so I'm going to let you
just go on from there and
feel free by the way if you're in the
audience to interrupt with questions and
so forth and uh if it gets to be a a
diversionary thing we'll either accept
it or not
okay
um let me uh
there we go
remove this
the zoom stuff was sort of in the way
all right
so thanks everybody for for coming and
um
feel free to interrupt ask questions at
any time and this is uh
what I'll be talking about is some uh
experiments I've done trying to create
apps just having conversations with a
language model but first maybe give you
a tiny bit of background so
I was doing good old-fashioned AI for
about 20 years first at the MIT AI lab
and then Xerox Park and so on and then I
got into the idea of creating a
programming language for children that
was completely based around animation
there was no text involved and uh
and then
in the middle of that I also got
involved in Oxford in a big project
trying to make it possible for
um
people to make agent-based simulations
of you know epidemics or ant colonies or
uh whatever
and then I got involved in 2016 in a big
European research project where my role
was to make it possible for the students
and these were 11 to 14 year olds to be
able to incorporate machine learning in
their projects so I built upon the snap
programming language which is more adult
version of scratch
and added lots of blocks for doing
computer vision or natural language
processing or to be even even able to
just create
um
neural networks and train them right
there in the browser and that was my
focus until
chat GPT came along and
um and I've been focused on
treating chat GPT as a colleague here
so I'm going to give a really detailed
story about one conversation I had with
chat GPT which involved building a
fireworks application and then I'm going
to
um
touch on some of these other examples
that I've also done with the chat GPT
and I keep saying chat GPT and um
I started it with the older one but as
soon as I had access to gpt4 I only used
the GPT
poor version of it which is just so much
more capable than any of the other ones
and I've done
attempts to see if I could do it with
with Microsoft Bing or Google's Bard or
hugging chat or Claude from anthropic or
Pi which just came out and
um all of them did pretty poorly
though I did just read that today
Google's uh said they're going to be
announcing a new version of Bard that's
more capable in generating code so maybe
it would be an equally good alternative
and I didn't really explore very
carefully the older version of chat GPT
so the first example I'll give you is
where the CH I asked chat GPT to be more
like a tutor and and I myself pretended
to be a student
but then the other six examples it's
much more a pair programming where
the
chatbot is really doing all of the
programming
and I'm kind of the Navigator kind of
saying oh we should try this so that's
not working or what about this problem
uh I also have to just because of the
current technology do a little bit of
copy and paste but that's very
mechanical and not very interesting
so first thing to understand is that
these are much more than just uh code
generators that they
um let me move this
um
they could they just by their nature
will will not just give you code but
give you explanations of what's going on
in the bigger picture and how that works
and uh and then if you ask it'll always
put some comments in the code but if you
don't really understand some function
you could just ask it to comment it and
it'll
every little section it'll put in
comments and not just sort of meaning I
mean redundant comments but ones that
are actually quite helpful
and you could always ask questions why
you know what is this primitive doing or
how does this function work or and you
tend to get back really useful answers
and the other thing is it's it often
makes constructs buggy code but if you
tell it about the bugs especially if you
just copy and paste the error messages
into the chat it can fix them
and then if you ask it and you say okay
could you think of ways to improve this
app it'll come up with a lot of sensible
suggestions
um and then there's been cases where it
couldn't generate some code because it
was trained two years ago and there it
was using an API that's much newer than
that and all I did was copy and paste
the documentation into the uh chat GPT
and you know read it in seconds and was
able to generate code and it could also
generate documentation
and it's also important especially when
you're thinking about children using
this that you could set you could tell
it from the beginning you know uh you're
talking to uh
a young child and it'll use a different
kind of uh vocabulary and avoid more
technical things and so on
so I all of these experiments I decided
to use uh ask it to to create a web app
in JavaScript and it was some HTML and
CSS
and the reason for that is these three
reasons is that
there's nothing for anyone we need to
install because everybody's got a
browser and browsers are so capable
these days you know they've got
speech synthesis speech recognition they
you know they could easily communicate
with all sorts of apis and so on
and uh
and then it's so much easier for people
to share you you could actually just
send the
index.html file in the script.js file to
your friends or you could host at any
number of places for free just as static
web pages
you don't have to run a server or
anything
and uh what professional programmers are
using I recently read a survey that said
something like about 75 percent of
people that are using large language
models to help with their programming or
using the visual studio co-pilot but 20
25 percent are doing what I'm doing
which is just to have a conversation
with a chatbot that could program rather
than have it nicely integrated and of
course being nicely integrated you know
you don't have to do the copy and paste
and it maybe understands more of the
bigger context it's it's a but it's much
too complicated to imagine
a typical
student using it
okay so the example that I want to start
with is this fireworks one which
um
as I said before this one's a little
different than the other ones I'm going
to talk about because I I mean I asked
it from the beginning to be more like a
tutor than just a colleague
and it
as you'll see there's
myself or my the Persona I was
pretending to be this you know needed to
know something about JavaScript but not
that much
and I'll show you the the result in a
minute but let's
um just go through what this
conversation was all about
so
um
I assume everybody could read this the
fonts big enough and all that the
the
um i s I started it off by just saying
you're a tutor for beginner programmers
First Learning JavaScript you provide
hints and explanations but never provide
complete Solutions instead you nudge the
learner towards Solutions
and it says sure I'll be happy to help
and then I said can you uh how can I
program a display of fireworks
and it says oh well using a canvas is
probably the best way to go and then it
actually comes up with this uh whatever
it is eight point plan for how to
actually build this including you know
making different classes and
having an animate and so on
so this is one of the few places where
this very nice tool called sharegpt.com
fell down which is it makes for a really
nice way of sharing your uh
uh your conversation with with GPT you
just push a button and it creates a URL
that has the entire thing but for some
reason this because I copy and pasted
here this tiny little index HTML file
ahead but what it was I'll tell you
right now is is simply it said here to
create it create a canvas
um
so it was just basically the rare bones
of a
HTML file with a canvas so nothing
really else and you know it's
the response always in this real nice
encouraging friendly way that a good
trigger maybe should be you know well
that was a good starting point or
recommending a few more things you could
add these more features and then it
generates this and you could just simply
in the
live version of this I just click on
copy code and then it's on the clipboard
and then I just create a folder called
fireworks and I create a file called
index.html and just paste this into it
you know so I don't really need to be
um
very technically competent to have this
kind of experience
so then remember it said also here
that I should use this get element by ID
and get context so I'm assuming I knew a
little bit here so I said you know oh I
I just started I did these two lines of
code
and it's you know great start and all
that so then it suggests that I
um size the canvas and have it uh adjust
whenever the browsing Windows is
um
resize so that you always have a canvas
that's the right size
so I just again you know copy code and
just pasted it in
but it said the next thing it said here
was to create a class for fireworks
so I pretended not to know how to do
that
so I said how do I define a class and it
gives a nice explanation and gives a
nice little generic uh example of a
class
and how you can make an instance
and then I actually made this mistake I
I meant to say how's this and paste in
my uh little bit of code but it it
noticed that I forgot to include with
the code that it wanted me to review so
here so then I just pasted it in so this
is you know my attempt to be a beginning
student who kind of figured out from
what it was saying that this is what
what I should do
and uh again you know it's encouraging
it's on the right track but here's a few
suggestions you know the convention is
this should be kept start with a capital
letter uh you know I should have a
update method and maybe adding gravity
would be good so
so it suggests this update and then
I should Define these two methods
um
and then I was thinking
that I uh you know if I'm uh I'm
assuming that a student at least
understands a little bit about velocity
velocity and gravity if not they I'm
sure they could have asked check GPT
here but but I didn't know whether it
would matter if I update the vertical
position and then update the velocity or
update the Velocity in the numerical
position
and um it says differenceably minimal
but most people do it this way and it's
a little bit better to do it in this
order and then it gives me uh
the the code for
so at that point I pretend not to know
how to how to actually draw the
fireworks rocket
and uh you know it says oh well you know
we could do it the simplest thing would
be to make it be a circle and here's the
code and notice it generated all these
comments in it and so on and then it
gives a nice explanation of how this
works and what it's doing
so now I have the bare minimum of this
program but I I I'm guessing I'm
pretending that I have no idea how to
even test this
so it says oh well you could create a
sample fireworks with these
parameters
and then create an animation Loop
that just continually calls update and
draws
and again it explains what's going on
and how to get this to work and and then
it says you know just
you know this code should be in the file
called fireworks.js and then just click
on the index.html file in the browser
and you'll see it working
and then I it wasn't working
so
um
so I was smart enough to say well how
could I see if there's an error message
and then it tells me about different
ways I could get to the console and see
what an error message is
and then I copy and pasted the error
message in here
and it realized that
the problem was that the JavaScript was
running before the page had fully loaded
and it gives two two ways of solving
this you use the windows on load or you
could simply move the script
uh later in the HTML
and I did the letter
so at that point I I saw the a rocket go
up
um but I it was it wasn't exploding yet
of course so I I didn't have a good idea
how to do the explosion and it comes up
with this
plan
for how to do it and a basic outline of
how to implement it
um
you know where the it makes
50 particles and they all go off in
random directions
and with some random speeds and
um
so then uh
I thought well it wasn't clear if I
should just because the
the fireworks rocket and the particles
were had very similar ways of being
drawn and being updated whether I should
really just copy the same code and then
it says oh well you know you could
create a base class
and then have
called moving object and then fireworks
and particles could be
um
subclasses that extended and again it's
just giving you the sketch of how to do
it it doesn't fill in everything for you
or right now
so
um
so I kind of followed this advice but I
didn't understand again how I could test
it because
remember the test before was just
whether you could get a rocket to go up
but how do I test the explosion and it's
comes up with again a nice little plan
for
for doing it how to uh
and then it gives the sort of sketch of
the of the code
um and at least some things for me to do
with someone but
uh and again it explains what to do
um
so
um so it was giving me explanations and
I said how about
how about this uh for creating a test
fireworks
and uh it said it looks good and
um
and it'll create one you know explains
what it'll do and it'll be at the bottom
and somewhere uh but it'll be read and
initial velocity and with gravity or
something and then it's trying to be
kind of again I think it's pretty good
that it doesn't just
um
make me feel like I'm
you know ignorant and it's so
knowledgeable it says well here's a
small suggestion you know be nice to
make uh the colors uh random rather than
just oh all the all of them being read
and provides a very simple little
function for coming up with a random
color and then shows how I could use it
so I tried all that and I remember
uh it doesn't have any idea what uh
what's going on I have to always tell it
how things are going and I said I think
the fireworks would only go about a
third of the way up
of the screen and blow up and they
weren't using the full canvas and it
gives a nice explanation that that
depending on the initial velocity and
the gravity value they may not be in
Balance so it suggests that I
uh increase the velocity and decrease
gravity
and I tried it and now they flew off the
top of the canvas but because it kind of
explained what was going on I just only
increase the velocity and left gravity
alone and was working just fine
so and you know and it approved my
uh changes to its suggestions
and
um
you know it's saying there's no correct
value you could play with different ones
you could explore you know until you get
something you're happy with or something
so then I asked well how can I add sound
effects to this
and it explains that there's the audio
API built into the browser and it can
read file I mean play files of these
extensions and it creates a tiny little
function for doing it
and it suggests that you know you put
play sound of the launch when the
fireworks are created and then you uh
play the explosion when
um when they when it explodes
and then
I ask it can you help how would you
suggest I search for the two sounds that
we need and it's certainly there's a lot
of websites with three year paid ones
and it says this one is a collaborative
one but Creative Commons license sound
and then it even suggests maybe it was
up here yeah that the keywords I
searched for fireworks launch or rocket
launch or fireworks explosion
so I I put them in just as it suggested
and then I thought it'd be nice to have
a button that when you push starts
everything up rather than it just uh
happens
so
um
so it says well you could just add
uh this um
button to your uh
HTML and then
um
and then in your JavaScript get hold of
that button and put a listener that and
it had this idea that
you don't start the fireworks until some
Global variable is set
and I could have just copied that but I
said you know I understood that if all I
want to do is when the button is pushed
that it starts animating why not just
start animating so I said can't I just
do that and it says oh yeah you're right
that's more direct and you know
straightforward and you know said don't
don't add this
start fireworks flag but instead you
know
uh use this kind of code
or change the code you know with this
aspect
um
and then I noticed that the
the
request animation frame used to be at
the the first thing it did and that was
the last thing and I just got curious
and said does it matter whether it's at
the beginning of the end and it it says
it can have an impact but the difference
is usually subtle and explains how
there's a risk that if you if you do it
in the beginning you might be
um
uh you might lead to some performance
issues and so on
so everything was working and then I uh
in one of some of the suggested code
there was a comment saying that uh you
should I should Implement something that
would remove the particles
um
and um I just said you know you said I
should remove the particles but I'm
doing and everything's working fine
anyways
and it explains that you know basically
if you're
I might end up consuming a lot more
memory and processing
on particles that are no longer visible
or relevant and that could lead to
making everything go slow or use a lot
of memory and it suggests
um a lifespan but I said I'd rather have
it just remove when they're no longer
visible when it said sure that's
reasonable and
generated the condition here for
when a particles off the outside
not visible anymore
and so everything was working but there
was an annoying little scroll bars and
horizontally and vertical and
um
so I said I see these scroll bars and it
it said well maybe it's because the
canvas and the page aren't the right
size and it suggested all this but
actually that that's very close to what
it had before
and I said it didn't help and then it
came up with
some more CSS to kind of deal with it
and I said yeah a little bit better but
because the scroll Bars were
you know less of an issue but they still
were there I mean there was a very
little scrolling involved
so then it said well maybe we just have
to remove a few pixels from the window
dimensions of uh for the canvas and it's
suggested removing you know uh four
pixels and I tried it and it didn't work
but when I to 10 it was fine
so everything was fine and then I said
well you know fireworks should happen at
night it should be a black background so
it just generated you know these two
lines of code here rather than clearing
it and then I said I can't think of any
other improvements can you and it came
up with what is this nine different
improvements you know a couple of them
actually were already done I didn't seem
to remember
that had already randomized the colors
and had a variable radius but
uh but it could have you know we could
add wind or air resistance we could have
more different shapes we could have a
trail
you know more user activity you know
um so I thought well I'll just pick one
of this number five
so it suggested adding you know an alpha
value
and
um and then the update uh uh uses it
um but notice that
um there's this thing called Global
Alpha and I would have thought somehow
Alpha itself was all
so I just I never heard of global Alpha
what is it and it's gives me a nice
explanation and how it works and why
he's using it and so on
so then
um
uh when I tried doing the change that it
suggested
uh I got this error message that that
you must call the super Constructor in a
derived class
since I was altering this
some class without calling the super and
it said oh you just have to add this
line
um
and um
so that fixed that problem and then I
said
um you know it would be nice if the app
actually
had a little note saying this was
created with the help of gpt4 uh and
having a link to the log and it created
all this nice CSS and it created this
uh div with the description and the link
and so on
and then it generated all this code but
it actually forgot
to add the
uh include the
JavaScript script the script element had
been there and it just forgot it when I
was putting this in so I just said
you've but right again this is just this
wasn't a problem originally this is a
problem with the
shared GPT that sometimes when I Pace
things they don't somehow make it into
this history
um
so then I said you forgot this but I
added it and then we want to remove the
button after it's clicked and
everything's working out but this is a
problem that happens on many of the
occasions which is
it used the word init here
well earlier it was using the the name
of the function was animate
and I told it you know I fixed it but
you you know
but I think because these conversations
get long and the context is limited to I
don't know I think it's up to 8 000
tokens for chat gpt4 and there's a 32
K version that uh to access to but
um
but so as a result it's kind of
forgetting some of the earlier stuff
that it told me and it was just guessing
and this is a common problem I'll show
you where it forgets exactly what a
variable name or function name is and
then it generates code with a similar
name with the same kind of concept but
but obviously one that won't work
because
computer programming languages need the
exact same name
so let me show you the results of all of
this
so if I click here
[Music]
I was pretty happy
with this
one
cool
yeah so
and that took I don't know uh
less than two hours I probably should
have kept track of the timing the whole
experience but
I thought you know it was a very
promising kind of experience in terms of
how helpful it was how much it was
suggesting things how good the
suggestions were how much I understood
about things and how much it could
explain things
so
that's what I want to say about
fireworks
um
so one thing that everybody's been
talking about with these chat Bots is
how important it is to do prompt
engineering and there are many contexts
which really is important but I've been
surprised for almost all my experiments
I very very rarely
did any
um attempt to make good prompts you know
as I would copy and paste an error
instead of saying well this is the error
I found in the console or
so and this was the only one where I
wanted it to be more of a tutor so I had
this this sorry this prompt here but
that was
um
pretty much the only exception where I
wasn't just having an ordinary
conversation with it and I haven't
bothered to make it uh use speech
instead of typing these things but
that's
straightforward to do especially because
you know browsers have
uh
speech recognition apis
okay so let me um
tell you a little bit about uh these six
other experiments I did
okay so
um
right
so here I wasn't playing the half skiing
to play the role of a tutor I was
treating it very much like pair
programming and
um
I'm more the Navigator suggesting things
and chat GPT is the the one actually
generating the code or something so I
said how can I create a web page with a
button that when clicked speaks a random
integer less than 1000 in a random
language pitch rate invoice
so we
um
you know told me here's some HTML here's
the JavaScript
it had just three languages but said you
could add more
and it understood all about the
the
speech synthesis
API that the you know HTML5
all the browsers uh
um and it's picking a random pitch a
random rate and a random language
and uh reporting errors and stuff
so um
so
just with what the first pass like this
when I clicked on the button
um I saw that there was this error no
voices available but then if I clicked
again everything worked fine from then
on
and it understood exactly what was going
wrong which is that the get voices is
asynchronous and they they may not have
been loaded when the first time you
clicked on the button but then the
second time it has is loaded so you
could
um program
around this by
um
uh
using a
on voices changed so that you you don't
try to say anything until you this flag
has been said that the voices have been
loaded
um so that worked
and then I said oh it'll be nice to
display what the number is and the
language and I said Etc and it
understood perfectly well that meant the
pitch and the rate and so on
and also I didn't really like the idea
of having to go to the console to see an
error message so could you report it
some other way
and you know it updated the HTML updated
the the uh
JavaScript
and then uh it was pretty ugly so I just
simply said and CSS I didn't you know
say more than that and it generated some
reasonable CSS to make it all look nicer
and explaining what it was and stuff
and then
um
rather than have just those three
languages baked into it I said why don't
you add all the languages that are
available in Chrome and I said in Chrome
but it actually comes up and it says
Chrome here too but it actually comes up
with a solution that'll work for any
uh browser because it's just collecting
all the languages that the browser has
available and then pulling out the
language code uh
from those languages
voices
so
um
so that worked and I I had a working uh
version of this but then I thought it'd
be nice to have a an additional
um capability in this app
so I said add a cartoon image of a
parrot and when you click on it repeats
what the user says with a random
language pitch rate invoice
so it you know it has this uh Paradigm
thing and it says you know I should put
replace that with my path to whatever I
put the parrot image and then it knew
perfectly well how to use the speech
recognition
um
API to pick up what somebody was saying
and that worked and then I said well
give the user feedback as to what text
it was it actually had heard along with
the other things that were there
and um
and then I said you know we had a button
for speaking random number but I said
use this file again and you could see
this is basically I went to Dolly and
said you know a colorful collection of
random integers
and it generated that image and I just
asked it to incorporate it in the app
um and then it didn't look so nice there
were vertical and they were kind of
small so I said make them larger and lay
them out horizontally and it had no
problems doing that
and then I I just thought you know how
would you explain what this app does to
a young child and
it says the app head has two pictures
one of colorful numbers another parent
when you click on the picture of
colorful numbers the Apple make your
computer or phone say a random number
it's like picking a number out of a hat
but the computer does it for you so it's
really trying to you know explain this
at a
to a young child pretty well I think and
you know it's even more fun is the
number will be spoken in a different
language voice speed each time and now
when you click on a parrot picture the
app listens to what you say just like a
parrot listening to you talk and then
the parrot actually the computer
pretending to be the parent will repeat
what you get really nice I thought
explanation
um and then I
said well
can it translate what was heard
and it says sure you could use Google
Translate and you need an API key and
here's the the
way to talk to that API and now you
should you know put it to API key here
and it goes on and on
and I
um
asked you know so the API key shouldn't
be backed in it should ask for it and uh
um
uh and then I um
I I have a I thought it might be better
to use hugging face instead of Google
translate so I said how about using
hungry face instead and it was perfectly
fine to use hugging face but then when I
tried it I kept getting these error
messages
and
uh what was really happening was that
um
when you ask hugging face to use a a
particular model
if it wasn't already loaded it'll load
it and give you back a response saying
it's loading please wait an estimated
you know 10 seconds or something but the
code wasn't paying attention to that and
also I didn't really want it to wait so
even though it it explained what was
going on and how to fix it I just went
and got a Google translate
um
key and
so let me show you the result
so I'm not going to bother with the
translate because I have to get my key
and paste it and all that but it works
perfectly fine without it so if I click
here
so I picked Italian a very high pitch
and a low rate or 408.
and then if I do this it should be uh
listen it should be
oh yeah
it should be listening to me as I speak
it should be listening to my speaker
and again if I if we had the API key you
would have translated that to French and
say that
and again I have this
link to the the dialogues you could
actually see how this was created
and
I have to mention that this parrot my
two-year-old granddaughter just giggled
and giggled and giggled when we'd say
things to it and it would repeat it it
would repeat it in a funny voice or
something and would repeat it in a funny
voice or something
you thought that was just so funny okay
um
so let me uh
talk about the next one
so I said how can I make a web page that
detects which way I'm pointing my finger
and uses it to draw on a canvas so my
original concept was that if I pointed
this way it would draw that way if I
pointed the switch or that way and so on
but it misunderstood me but actually
came up with it equally good scheme that
I wasn't didn't bother uh
pursuing so what's so interesting about
this is just from this
it uh
you know does it generates all this HTML
CSS but the JavaScript actually I think
it says it here too that it yeah it's
actually going to use a machine learning
model that's um a hand pose that'll
figure out you know 33 different uh
locations on your finger you know that
each joint and so on
and
um it knows how to load it and use it
and so on oh and also of course how to
get the video feed going into it uh and
then here how to load the
tensorflow.js uh library and then how to
load the hand pose model and how to use
it and then how to use it to detect if
I'm my fingers pointing upward
and um and this is what an interesting
thing that sometimes it's generating
code and just stops in the middle
um or the in this case the explanation
and that's because you know the
it only does so much of a completion
it's limited to I don't know thousand or
two thousand tokens or something but if
you just say please continue it just
apologizes and just starts right where
pretty much where I left off and and you
know continues generating the code
and then I said well nothing's being
drawn and it says oh there's some issue
about the position on the canvas and it
turns out it was a bit confused about
the two the coordinate system of the
um and pose and the coordinate system of
the canvas but
um
it it tried to fix it and then I said
well now it's only drawing in a small
area and it finally you know gets it
right with some changes
and then this is this problem where it
uh it uses some variable called
predictions but
um
but it was oh in this case I think it
was a scoping error but sometimes it's
because it had a different name in some
other part of the code so it suggests
how to pass the
uh make it available here
um and then I said well how about if you
say the a color it'll change to the
color that the user spoke and it
um
we once again uses speech recognition
and uh and
uh only accepts you know these 10
different colors and if if you um say
any of this if if what you said includes
any of the these 10 colors then it'll
switch to that color
and there's a default color or black and
so on
uh and then it turned out it worked the
first time but only the first time and
it said whoops sorry for the confusion I
should be using the API built
differently and it regenerates the code
and everything's working and I said well
let's display what what the last thing
spoken in the current color so that
people know that it's hearing it and
then this was very nice I just said add
instructions on how to use the app and
it generates you know the the
HTML to explain how to use it and to
make some CSS to make that look nice
and then somehow the display didn't get
right
um
again because I think it was forgetting
what it was calling things before and it
was using different a similar but
different names here
and again the same problem that it
couldn't it picked up the wrong variable
name or something
[Music]
um
so it's like the problem might have been
that uh we were doing things before the
page was loaded but that wasn't really
the problem so I said that we if that
didn't fix it and then I said just I
didn't have to say much more same
problem and it tries another way to fix
it that didn't help so I had an idea
what was wrong but I wasn't right either
and it said I thought maybe that was the
issue
um
so oh and also notice this problem like
you know whether it was calling it video
or webcam it wasn't consistently naming
things
so anyways I finally got it all uh
working and
and I didn't understand what happened so
somehow it started to work even though
these changes didn't seem I don't know
uh
but then there was a really minor
problem that took forever to fix which
was it was showing
the last thing that it heard and then
the color all in the same line and it
would look nicer if they're on separate
lines and it it just keeps not getting
it right and finally
uh you know I said maybe it's this
something to do with the overlay
and then it comes up with this um
solution that I didn't even know about
there was some fancy um
CSS to deal with the problem
uh
problems so everything's working fine
and then I said you know could you
explain to a 10 year old how it would
work and once again it does a really
nice job of explaining how this thing
works and let me show you
how it what it's like
oh but uh I have to turn off the uh
video turn off the video around
no I've been tried loading it again
um
so notice that it generated these uh
instructions all by itself and uh
see it turned off
the video oh here it comes good so now
if I move my finger like this and I say
red red blue blue
it's kind of you know it's working
pretty awesome but I'm able to to draw
all over it with my finger yeah
a five-year-old or a ten-year-old will
really like that
yeah no actually my granddaughter this
was funny too that I could drive
okay so uh but that was what I thought
was interesting was you know it had no
troubles loading a machine learning
model using it appropriately to get the
hand poses it just knew how to do all
those sort of things
so the next example I wanted to talk
about is
um
if some some
person wanted to actually do a little
bit of machine learning on some of their
own data so I had this
spreadsheet which was had just 60
examples 20 examples of some text that
shows a lot of confidence 20 examples
that shows a real lack of confidence in
20 that were kind of neutral
and I said how can I make a web page
that would predict the level of
confidence of some new text
and it gives you know an ex gives some
suggestions and and but oh but but I
didn't say anything about JavaScript so
it thought oh I should just do this all
in Python and then I said no no I don't
want to do it in Python how could I do
in JavaScript and then it says so here's
how you could do it using node and I I
just wanted a web page so I say no I
don't want to use node I only want the
browser and it's oh well here's how we
could do it
so
um
you know it's loading tensorflow.js it
creates the model a very small model and
compiles it and does the training and
um and then does the prediction and
shows the shows what's going on and
again it stopped right in the middle of
it generating on just said continue and
it continued generating
and then it said you know I should have
um these two files
um
and then I have to put the the CSV file
somewhere in that same folder or
something so it actually uh worked but
yeah there was no feedback that while I
was training so I said can you make a
graph of the training loss and
um so it it loads some library and it
knows perfectly well how to integrate
this Library uh with the Callback of the
training
and
it worked but the plot was much bigger
than the
page and it looked pretty ugly so I said
it was too big and in CSS I made it nice
makes it look nicer
and then I said you know why don't why
didn't you show the likelihood scores
for the predictions and it doesn't could
do that and it does
and then I asked how can I make this
more accurate because it wasn't very
accurate and it says well you could have
more data you could do some
pre-processing orientation you could
change the model architecture you could
um you know all these things
and I said well how about you improve
the model architecture and it says sure
and it makes a a bigger
model with more layers and
um
and then I said well maybe the user
wants to explore how many epochs that
give a interface so the user could enter
how many epochs they want
and the graph came up after it was
finished training so I said could you
make the graph be updated while it's
doing the training and it's a true and
how to do that
and I'm going to finish and then I said
could the the training function was
pretty complicated so I said could you
add comments to it and notice you know
for each section it says okay you know
getting the inputs preparing the data
creating the model
starting up the graph you know setting
up the Callback and it just goes on and
on explaining it nicely
and then
um I happen to notice that um it was
gave very different answers depending on
whether it had uppercase or not and it
understood exactly what was going on
that it was using the universal sentence
encoder and it's pretty sensitive and it
can um
it could easily fix this by of course
just taking whatever the user input and
sending it to lower case so there wasn't
that difference and there it was so
let's see it in action
so I'm gonna say I don't know 80s that's
just because
so it says training but it's actually
um
uh coming up with the embeddings for the
60 sentences and there is that now I get
the training and the see the validation
loss is going up and there's a so it's
overfitting or something but I could
type something here like
I'm sure
I say predict
and it says
99.7 sure that it's competent and I say
uh
uh and there we go and then uh
well I didn't do so good should have
been neutral but I thought that was well
maybe it's showing some confidence
anyway so that I thought was pretty
impressive that it could do something
like that
um
so
let's see so in terms of timing I I uh I
don't want to show all of these because
they'll take too long but I wanted to uh
I think I'll show two more but I'll try
to go quickly is that yeah
okay so this one
is using asking chat GPT to use GPT to
make a uh a conversation between uh
personas
and
um
but you know he knows how to uh
well I actually didn't know how to call
the uh
the API
um
oh but so at various points I had to
copy and paste the documentation from
their website and it then was able to to
do it fine
um
and
again it was trying to use node I said
no no I don't want to and this is
interesting that it says well if you're
using the API key in the front end
that's a little bit not recommended
because the key could get
um
somebody might be able to get your key
or whatever
um
Let Me Maybe This one uh I could just oh
I do want to um
show you one bug that was so funny yeah
here it is and
so there's trying to be a conversation
between Aristotle and Galileo but but at
this point in in the progress it
Aristotle says I am Galileo and Galileo
says I am Aristotle I am not Galileo and
the nearest summer says I am Galileo I
am Galileo I am both Aristo it just was
totally crazy but it understood what was
wrong here and how to you know uh change
the roles and and the the right uh
messages to the chat system such that
um
uh let me show you uh well actually just
an interest of time I'll just show you a
screenshot
um
so uh
so you could enter any two people here
and then you could join in by just
typing a message here and saying send
so gallios greets Aristotle and they're
both really polite to each other and
they appreciate these kind words and
voila and then I jump in and say well
how fast do objects fall and Aristotle
says to Galileo you know
some people have challenged it seems to
know things that have said happy died
but you know that his motion it is
emotion of a challenge but he still
maintains the speeds proportional to the
weight and Galia says you know
uh oh and they refer to some weird bug
where it's it actually repeats this
twice and I I mentioned it to chat GPT
but I made the mistake of mentioning
that and another problem and it dealt
with the other problem and I never came
back to figuring out why sometimes it
repeats but anyways
um
Aristotle's respectfully disagreeing and
explaining this and uh so it was a nice
little you know a little app
create these subsidies
um
and so let me show you the the
most complicated one
I'll tell you real quick well I'll just
show you this one readily
on this one
um the flowers are all fading away and
shrinking but I could drop water
balloons on them and they get bigger or
something
okay
[Laughter]
you know
so you know it's hard to keep watering
all these flowers you know so that's
that that was what it uh you know we did
with a little conversation but this was
a funny one because it actually was
partially working and then it in trying
to add another feature it broke some of
the earlier stuff and then it just
wasn't it it this was about the only
time when I really had some
um
not very good results but then I'm going
to start it over again it actually did
well and also I have links here for how
you know Bart did trying this or
something
okay so this is the um
the really big ambitious one that I did
it's
um I counted it I think 111
exchanges back and forth
and in the beginning when I
asking it to do is to
um
create uh generate a story and I picked
this uh because
um
you know Guymon in Sandman there's the
story where this character has kidnapped
the Muse and for punishment
he's
getting so many ideas for stories that
it's that he's going crazy can't think
of anything other than stories and
there's like a lot of crazy stories
including a man who falls in love with a
paper doll so I actually did all 15 that
came from that story plus some other
ones that I invented
anyways so it generates you know three
paragraphs like like I asked and then I
said can you criticize them and it says
oh well we could do this character
development or better setting and it's
not generic ones it's saying the town
the theater was only briefly mentioned
maybe you could improve that or
something and I say oh well apply
suggestions one and four and it does
that and then I say well it's Chris you
know come up with criticism for the
second paragraph So it's able to
criticize its own generation its own
creations and then apply changes
so then I so put it all together into a
single story and then I said
uh generate a description of an
illustration for each paragraph include
the medium the artistic style mood point
of view lighting and the like and it
comes up with these kinds of things so
then at that point I said well I'd like
to make a web page in which you could do
this interactively and then
um
it works but then
um eventually works I should say and
this is a place where it didn't know how
to use the dolly
API but I just uh
pasted the documentation and you know
it's really just copy and paste it with
all the you know crazy stuff that
happens when you just copy and paste but
it still understood it well enough to
generate the right code
and
um
so then I uh it goes on and on very long
this one I
once I got it working for that I said
well let's make it work for any story
and let's make it so that you could
criticize the uh illustrations and
generate new ones and so on and maybe
I'll show you the final result here
uh
uh here it is
oh by the way I even if you if you want
to get it
an idea of how I did this without going
through the entire
111 things I I kind of highlighted the
main things of what I did and what
happened and what was going on here um
and uh yeah and then
the uh here it is
so it by the way it generated all of the
the the instructions here
so it it tells you again this is I just
said add-ins add instructions in the
beginning with a button to close them
and it explains how this whole thing
works
so then
um
uh
you know needs my uh key there and then
I say
um
I didn't try this before three three is
probably good
so one thing you could do here was I
added this button that could actually
show you
the communications with
gpt4 and with Dolly so you could see
what actually is you know it it does
um
so this shouldn't take more than another
less than a minute I think
so this is going to have all of those
features that I kind of experimented
with in the dialogue so you could ask
for ask it to generate criticism you
could decide to apply the criticism
to rewrite a paragraph and you could
also get criticism about the
illustrations
and you could even enter your own
criticism of an illustration and it'll
regenerate wo
update the
the illustration prompt and then
generate a new uh story and it should uh
interleave the text and the
um
images
so
um
one of the problems with using gpd4 is
that it's so much slower than 3.5 3.5
would
have you know done this long ago but
Ford does just as such a nicer job that
I
tend not to use it obviously I could
have asked gpt4 to make an interface
where you could decide which which model
you want to use for doing this
um maybe what I should do oh here it
comes finally
so I stood nervously at the podium of
the prestigious Stanford University
preparing company an elite seminar
Series in electrical engineering he had
spent countless hours perfecting his
presentation and sustainable energy
systems and was the culmination of
cyborg as he looked out at the Gathering
of intelligent faces eager to hear what
he had to say he felt a sense of Pride
but also mounting pressure to deliver
mounts and here I am giving the speech
and if I
um if I hover over it we could see that
it says the illustrations of watercolor
painting with the realistic and softly
Blended colors depicting the anxious Ken
standing at the podium the setting as
well lit Hall with the iconic Stanford
University seal in the background I
don't know if that's true
um gentle lighting enhancing it and
intensity the point of view is from the
audience looking up so it's a bit
confused because the audience is there
and it's looking at the audience but
this is a dolly problem it's actually
generated so if I click on this
here's the the description
and
um
uh
uh oh that's interesting
well first oh maybe it's still thinking
because I think it's gonna it's gonna
show some
suggested changes to the uh
to the thing
I don't know so maybe I'll just say
I say apply changes so it'll rewrite the
description
um and then once it's the descriptions
were written I could hit so now it
should say yeah an oil painting with
realistic and then I say replace the
image and it'll generate a new one or
something
and even while this is happening I could
I think I could click oh here it comes
anyways so I'll close this
and there I am giving
a lecture it looks just like you yeah
and then if I click here I'll get some
criticism that it'll generate for the uh
first paragraph here
by the way we could see what the other
paragraphs look like well the audience
got excited here
uh this is the pro AI group yeah and
then uh
wow
it looks like everybody wanted my
autograph at the end uh
satisfied smile interacts with the
congratulatory crowd a warmer lady
creates a mood of accomplishment and
pride and it's pretty good as he
concluded the talk in any questions it
was clear that he made an impact
professors and students like approached
him praising this is pretty good
anyways uh if if we go here
so it generated seven suggestions for
how to change this paragraph
a better opening sentence uh
introduce more background on Ken so that
the readers understand my qualifications
or reasons for giving the talk
whatever
and I could even say here you know
change it from Energy Systems to chat
chapter so that's the um
the the most ambitious uh
apps that I created with uh
chat GPT so I'm practically finished
here
um so one question in my mind is
doing this does it automate away the fun
of programming
or is it better to think of this as
empowering people with very little
programming skills to create all sorts
of uh be very creative in creating apps
and
um Seymour pampert often wrote about
hard fun because uh one of the children
talked about how programming in logo was
was hard to fund that it was or he
probably said it was fun but hard at the
same time
so
um that's still the case but it's also
for a lot of children they find it
frustrating or too difficult and you
know just doesn't always work to
introduce a programming to to children
and
um
and also there's sometimes the teachers
don't aren't much support because they
don't understand very well how to
program either
so the the plus side is that by having a
collaboration like this anybody with
just an idea for an app that's
reasonable obviously if you wanted to
make
you know a triple A rated game or
something that you're not likely to
succeed but it could come to life
through this kind of process
well of course gpt4 is gpd4 there will
be a five and a six and a seven and an
eight yeah exactly that that's exactly
what I'm talking about the future here
so
um in the short term we could expect it
just to get you know more competent and
the gpt4 can uh
look at images and understand them but
that's only been released to a to a very
small number of uh testers
um and and some company that's producing
uh
software for blind people
um but but that's coming so you couldn't
you should be able to just like take a
screenshot of of a problem with your app
and then
say well here's here's what it what's
going on and it'll
interpret the image and
maybe figure out how to fix things
and this copy and paste thing is you
know obviously can be automated and
um
you know the probably as many of you
know about the the leaked Google Docs
that claims that uh the open source
alternatives to uh Bard and uh gpt4 are
getting so good that uh maybe the big
players don't really have any particular
Edge over what's going on in the open
source world
um so maybe that'll be uh something that
near term could be done but the long
term who knows it's clearly going to
keep getting better and uh and more
capable and so on
so I I asked Dolly to create a
watercolor painting for the question
answer portion of the talk and I said no
text should be included and it it you
know
well it didn't pay attention so uh
hopefully there are some questions
how do you like working with an AI as a
con as a colleague
yeah
um the the first thing the the fireworks
thing was the most Pleasant one because
it was it was trying to be
you know have this role more of a of a
tutor the um
the the other ones it was still you know
uh really interesting but I felt like it
was kind of writing this program and
asking me to do a lot of copying and
pasting you know and to report about
errors you know so that that was sort of
my role I would I mean of course that's
not quite Fair because what I also did
was
and this is maybe an important aspect of
this is that I always started with the
simplest version of the app that I had
in mind and once I got that I would ask
for a single enhancement and once that
works another one so I was I was I did
have a
an incremental plan for how the apps
should get billed that was purely mine
and and it was um you know my assistant
in that role but but often it was more
like you know
um
just telling me okay here's some code
replace this here's some code you know
copy and paste this and
um
but it was still something exciting
about the fact that you know it
understood me so well and I was um
and it was able to do so many things and
knew all these different apis and
uh was better at CSS than I am for sure
not hard
at least in my experience CSS is
not transferred
so
um I attended a talk at Stanford a
couple weeks ago and they did a study of
the security of the code generated I
think it was by co-pilot code generator
and they found that it was dismal in
fact programmers who used copilot
produce less secure code than those who
did not but the ones who did thought
their code was more secure and the
conclusion of that study was that the
assistant lacks context
um while you were showing some of the
examples I was just scrolling through
the text and it looks like it's the same
problem there that the assistant is
losing context
any comments on that yeah no that was
the other annoying thing was that it was
losing context and there were a few
times when I realize that it just
um had completely forgotten what the the
source code for so for a part of it or
so I would copy and paste something
pretty much earlier and said you know
and here's the this function or here's
this
um
uh HTML that we're we're using and that
often would would help because now it
was in the morning I wasn't thinking so
much of forgetting as it seemed that in
some cases it it misinterpreted the
context of what you were asking uh
because it didn't know the environment
in which you were working
yeah
um
well
generally
um I mean like I said example where with
the video one where I had originally
intended oh I should put my video back
on
um
um I originally intended you know that I
can point with my finger in different
directions and that would
indicate which way the the pen would
move or something as opposed to the way
it came up with but I was just as happy
with that rather than trying to get it
to uh
interpret it the way I intended but in
terms of security I thought it was
pretty impressive that it really tried
hard to talk me out of uh using the API
key in a static web page like this
on the other hand I you know I said you
know make it a password field and
um you know it's uh
it's not a really a problem that um that
a user is putting the key into a a web
page like this but of course
once it's hosted somewhere somebody has
to
trust that you're not stealing their key
but of course the the in every one of
these cases you could look at view
source and the code is actually quite
clear and nice so somebody could see
that the API key isn't uh sent off to
somebody or something
uh
so in in this kind of context I don't
think the security is such an issue but
obviously
uh if you're if you're making a some
kind of web service and you know there's
a lot more things to think about in
terms of security yeah I was I wasn't so
worried about security through these
apps as much as uh the context issue uh
there's so much implicit context that
the programmer has that the the
assistant does not
right yeah I I mentioned to be quite
different if I was doing some really
large project
uh
because you know
um so the the this last one the The
Illustrated story generator it did it
was a little more than 500 lines of
JavaScript so and um and that's actually
two large
for the at least the default version of
chat GPT I can't say
you know paste in this entire 500 lines
and say okay now let's uh modify it in
some way it's just too much context
I mean too many tokens for it to be
fitted context window so there are these
limitations of course the like I just
saw
today some startups saying they they've
got a context window of 50 000 tokens
well I've been you know using I think 8
000 or something
so that and there's even some research
paper that claimed that they had a a
million
uh token context that was using some
clever algorithms because you know the
the context normally is a quadratic
um
complexity but if you're clever you can
make it n log n or something
um
well I think I I
really blew it away again it's just uh
this is uh
[Music]
a very nice expression to how people
seem to be using the uh the uh
artificial intelligence
devices or remote personal Persona uh as
as a component in a larger system and I
guess now the ads we see for
um you know doctors who use Ai and
dentists who use Ai and people who play
with AI driven games and so forth uh has
has more context in terms of the current
AI systems
I think that's a very useful thing
yeah you're back
yeah
I think I I really appreciate the
introduction because I I had
not thought about this part of it I
always thought the hard part was
twiddling the knobs on the uh the uh the
data used to do run the AI but
just talking to the AI turns out to be
complex enough
yeah
um
you know if we go back a year you had to
give it you know several examples of
what you were intending and had to
engineer your prompt kind of carefully
to get it to be pretty competent but
gpt4 as I mentioned I really
just seemed much more of a natural
conversation
um and I'm really am curious to see how
you know a 12 year old deals with such
things you know better
probably better than you and I do yeah
that's right
you know my my favorite story is
watching a uh uh a non-speaking child
sort of order six months old stealing
his mother's phone and the per password
and then using it to play his video
uh this is this is adaptation at a very
low rate or a very high rate
Somebody's gotta somebody's got a
question are you watching the hands up
Dennis I'm not watching it at all
um
you know you wanna you wanna to uh call
people or put them up yeah go ahead you
got your hand up
yeah uh it's just
I had a question about
um
the
edges of the models uh understanding of
programming uh
is there any indication or what was your
experience in uh finding the edges of uh
the what the model knew about a
particular API or
uh or programming in general I mean it's
I was specifically thinking I use a
prototypical inheritance over the newer
class inheritance and I was just kind of
curious there's probably a lot less a
lot fewer code examples of that on the
on the internet
uh so probably less training data for
that I was just curious if you
encountered if you looked at
how the model degrades
yeah um
well I I didn't really but I did notice
something about the
it's coding Styles
um
and it wasn't always consistent like a
tiny example but maybe illustrative one
is that this problem about you know with
the javascript's trying to uh
get an element from the Dom but the page
hasn't loaded uh yet
it it was using sometimes this on load
as a you know
and sometimes it was using a listener to
on Dom content loaded which is what I've
read is the proper better way of doing
it the download is an older way that
isn't as good but it still kind of works
so so there is this kind of
um in that case there's two different
issues one is whether it's on load or on
Don Dom content load but also as to
whether it's using it's actually using
at event listener or whether it's just
setting the listener directly
and it kind of wasn't consistent
sometimes it would do one sometimes the
other and it you know again because I
guess
most of the
programs that I've looked at were
consistent about which way they would
deal with that just like a real
programmer yeah
uh no but
it's just a bit of a real program
intends to have us one style in which
they stick to for those kinds of tasks
but it was I thought it was a bit odd
that it was kind of flip-flopping about
whether it was
you know which way would deal with that
problem real programmers um coming back
six months later will not be consistent
with well that's true yeah
thank you uh very cool things it can do
conservative programming and you
mentioned the prompt engineering
um before so that it may not require any
more from engineering uh almost at all
so it doesn't recognized use of well and
do you also mentioned role playing as
one of the techniques so now there are
more developing stress on techniques
rather than engineering of prompt itself
but maybe from your experience of this
project uh what these techniques would
you found helpful uh maybe you found
something of your own that helped you to
navigate the chattvt4
um
well the the problem a little bit was
that
um
I
I was always really the the underlying
motivation for a lot of this was
thinking about you know
what kind of uh learning materials or
experience what I imagine like a high
school student having so I was rarely
kind of role playing myself I was often
you know pretending in my head you know
to be maybe a high school student I knew
a little bit about this and not much
about that or something
so uh
but what I uh maybe I'll try this soon
which is if especially if it's a younger
child I think if you set up the the
context better and I say you know
um you know you're going to be helping a
a nine-year-old who doesn't know much
about programming to build the apps that
they want you know be sure to explain
things
carefully and not use too much technical
jar use a set of set up a context like
that that it would tend to I believe it
but I haven't tried this that it would
tend to
uh
use language much more appropriate to
communicate with an angle because it
does there's two examples of where I
said after it's built an app I said well
could you explain to a nine-year-old or
it's young child how this app would work
it I thought it did a great job of
explaining it in in
you know the right kind of vocabulary
and the right kind of analogies
um
but I I should really
come up with a task that actually I want
to do and just stop pretending to be a
student and just see
you know what I could accomplish as well
I mean one reason I'm doing it this way
is I've always been interested in kids
in programming but also there's there's
an awful lot of
real programmers that are using uh chat
GPT to get accomplish their day-to-day
tasks so I thought this would be more of
a unique experience to think in terms of
of how children might deal with this
and when I say children of course it
could be an adult that knows no
programming a hobbyist or something but
I mean none
expert programmer
okay that's very interesting thank you
it's also recently I listened to podcast
is Lee chasen uh which was an educator
who also worked now on the quantum
strategies and he used role playing uh
in the beginning like he did with the
child to actually create a Content uh
for the children
so in terms of how they can study the
material because he was a teacher before
I think teaching history
and uses this prompts like overall
playing to actually create the tasks
that the children would understand or
certain
um output that would be
um better suited for the audience so
levels of understanding so I think what
you also showed here is how well it
works uh in terms of this first uh
example that you showed so that it
really expands you nicely as if you were
ended a younger adult or a child so
uh yes and my question may be also
additionally uh meant to ask what other
techniques if one helpful like maybe
it's not only role playing but something
else maybe some structuring or giving
examples uh will also help clinicals
yeah it was so part of the problem is
that at the same time I was doing this I
was also curious about
could it really understand me if I just
say you know
um a b Etc and I don't really list
everything out or if I say you know that
was it didn't go high enough without
giving much detail so I was kind of
really wanting to explore
how
uh how well it could do if I was
um not being very careful to give it
detailed instructions or a large amount
of context just to see you know could it
still
respond appropriately
um
one thing I should say too is that you
know the Khan Academy has
been working with chat GPT to make a
um a tutor that
they gave a demo of teaching algebra and
it was really very very good at giving
hints and giving feedback when the
student did things wrong but if the
student said well what's the answer
what's how do I solve this it'll it'll
keep saying no I'm I'm not going to give
you the answer but here's a hint or
something so
it was they had set up the context
appropriately so it it would not um
you know it would be a good pedagogic
tutor and not be just uh a chatbot that
would just give you answers when asked
when asked for it but in my my case I
thought
I thought
that it was I could have maybe tried to
uh early on say something like well
you're giving me too much
code you know I want to be able to do
more of it myself or something I could
have done that and it would have taken
me longer but it would have given me
more
hints and more little pieces to put
together but
um
but I think it's it was the way I did it
I think was plausible for some student
that you know would be happy with these
pretty high level things and some
copying pasting but also some creating
things on their own
um
thank you sure
any more questions
well Ken thank you very very much I love
being educated in this uh in this area
and uh uh yeah I I qualify as a barely
marginal student I just um and what
happens is I think that we see examples
of reverse aging that the young kids are
much more successful than the older
people and you know I'd like to claim
that I know how to do things but
oftentimes don't
um anyhow thank you very much